>> So, welcome to
the session on verification
and secure systems.
So, we're going to have
three speakers on this.
So, Ed Nightingale is going to
talk about Azure Sphere
and Secure Hardware.
Then Adams Apollo from MIT,
is going to be talking about
Formal Methods and how
that drives system design.
Then finally, Nick Swamy
from MS Labs is
going to be talking
about the Everest Project
and Verifying TLS.
So, let me go ahead and
turn it over to Ed.
>> Thanks, Chris.
You guys hear me?
Good morning, it's
my pleasure to be here.
My name is Ed Nightingale,
I'm one of the members of
the Azure Sphere Team.
This is a product that was
just announced this Spring.
This talk might be a bit of
a different altitude that I might
normally give at
a faculty summit,
we're really looking for
some engagement with
the academic communities
and feedback and I
love to talk to you
all later in the day.
So, and actually right now,
you can order development kit
if you're interested
in playing with
the Azure Sphere Product
or trying to hack
it, we'd love that.
It's what's Azure
Sphere focused on.
Azure Sphere is focused all
around microcontrollers.
Microcontrollers are
low-cost single-chip computers.
Microcontrollers are really in
all the devices around you,
in your home, in your hotel room,
at work that you
never think about.
There are nine billion
MCU based devices
built and deployed every year,
more than one per
person on the planet.
If it has a screen,
if it has a button,
or a low-risk screen, it's
got a microcontroller on it.
Now, what's the big change?
About four years ago,
you started to see
microcontrollers with a radio,
and a chip like this
is around $2.50.
So, if you said, "Well,
for $2.50 I can take
those nine billion devices
and connect them all
to the Internet."
I think for most of
this device you say,
obviously, we should
connect them,
it enables us to produce
new experiences,
enables us to interact
with them live in
a new connections with
the people who are
using those devices.
Now, the interesting
issue is that
only about one percent
of these MCU devices are
connected right now.
So, why is that?
Well, you have this huge
opportunity connectivity
and you also have
a large amount of risk.
We'll just gives you
a simple example.
I think everyone in this room has
used refrigerator and has one,
and a simple example
for connectivity is,
how do you know
whether the compressor
has failed in your refrigerator?
Well, without connectivity,
you wake up in the morning,
you've got melted ice cream
all over the floor.
With connectivity and
predictive maintenance,
you might get a phone call from
your device manufacturer and
they say, "You know what?
We've noticed your compressor
starting to fail;
can we stop by and replace it?
"Obviously, that's
a better experience
than the one with
the melted ice cream.
But what happens when
you connect the device
to the Internet?
Well, we all know
what happens if you
connect a device the Internet,
we've seen all the stories,
you've seen baby monitors
turned into spy devices,
you've seen refrigerators
are sending spam,
and you've seen
ransomware attacks,
hackers infect millions of
devices all over the world.
The other day I actually
took my router and
threw it at the trash
because the FBI,
so that's what I should do
with it because I couldn't
update the software remotely,
never done that before.
We're in a space where we have
this huge opportunity for
low-cost connectivity and we
have this massive amount of risk.
A really good example,
this is the Mirai
Botnet from 2016.
The Mirai botnet, these are
just simple IP cameras and
took down basically the Internet
on the East Coast of
the United States.
Now, what's scary about
the Mirai botnet?
It's only a 100,000 devices,
it's a tiny number of devices.
If you look at one market for
connectivity like
major appliances,
there are about 350
million major appliances
sold every year around the world.
A hundred thousand devices
can take down
a portion of Internet's
infrastructure,
imagine a billion refrigerators
involved beside the DDoS.
The other sad thing about
this attack is
well-known weakness.
I believe it was
a fixed password.
The password was shockingly
R-O-O-T. You couldn't change
the password, and even worse,
once they saw
the exploit happening,
there was no way to update
the software on it
to get rid of it,
it was just a mini-disaster.
Another great example
recently is that there is
a connected thermometer
in a fish tank,
similarly they able to hack it,
and they were able to
actually use this to bounce
over and attack at
database and get access
to high roller data.
So, we're in the Wild West.
We're in a space with IoT where
security is an afterthought,
what are we going to do?
Well, the first thing
we're going to do
is when we talk about
connectivity to major
manufacturers is,
why I'm going to beat
this dead horse?
Imagine that refrigerator,
you wake up in
the morning but instead
of melted ice cream you got
a text message on your phone,
it says, "We found your fridge,
send us Bitcoin or all
your ice cream melt."
The more important
one I think is,
you wake up in the morning
and 500,000 stoves are blown up.
There's actually a customer
we spoke with who had a stove
that was in development
and they did
a security audit after
we talked to them,
they figured out that
through a software
exploits they could turn
on the gas in the stove,
and an arbitrary
amount of time later,
they could light it.
So, that did not hit
the market, thankfully.
They caught that but
the risks are really real,
the risks are about physical
harm. Is this foundational?
I think everyone in this room
knows that security
is foundational,
and I think the issue is
really trying to create
platforms where security
comes from first principles.
So, what's Microsoft
doing about this?
What it's security
about? Well, there's
two things I want to talk about.
One, is that [inaudible]
authored a white paper called
The Seven Properties of
Highly Secure Devices.
These properties are measurable.
Now, why did we do this?
Well, we felt that there is
no bar someone can
look at when they
really are looking at
an IoT solution and
determine the level
of security they had.
Everyone's simply
says, "You're secure."
It's black and white,
it's a single bit.
Everyone in this room knows
that's not how security works.
This is us putting
a line of their marker,
this is the minimum bar,
any device that's connected
to the Internet should
meet to have the potential
to be secured.
So, you have a lot of
basics here, right?
You have a hardware
root of trust.
We have things like
defense in depth,
keeping your trusted
computing-based small,
certificate-based authentication,
failed reporting, and
renewable security.
So, this is up on the web
at aka.ms/7properties.
We'd love for you guys to read,
we'd love feedback
about it and have
a conversation about
these seven properties,
what those properties provide,
and why do you think
we've hit the mark there,
or you think that there's room
for more discussion
engagement here.
One of most important things
though is that
someone who's not
a security expert
at the very least could
take the Seven Properties
and just ask,
do I have the Seven Properties?
Do I have a hardware root
of trust in my device?
Do I have certificate-based
authentication?
If they don't, they can
start to ask, why not?
So, that's properties,
I want to talk in detail
about a couple of them.
Some of these properties only
depend on hardware
support and this is where
we're going to get
into the need for
secured silicon in addition
to software and services.
Class examples are
hardware root of trust.
It's unforgeable
cryptographic key,
protects the hardware's identity,
so it can't be spoofed.
Implements hardware for
things like secure boot,
so we guarantee they're
only sign software
runs on a device
and you eliminate
the possibility of random malware
being loaded and executed.
Some properties depend upon
hardware and software.
So for example, here's
a Dynamic Compartments.
Dynamic Compartment
you could think of as
your MMU that provides
address space translation and
process-based isolation
in operating system.
So, they made
compartments, I mean
these compartments can
change on the fly,
you can update them
and change them later
and provides protection
from one process,
as example, nothing I'll
take down another one.
So, last, some properties
depend upon hardware,
software, and the Cloud.
So, as an example here,
we think about renewable
security, what does that mean?
Simply means that we know it's
actually going to happen,
we know exploits can be found,
does an IoT device
have the ability
to update its software
remotely and securely?
This requires Cloud to
provide the updates,
software to apply that update,
and hardware to provide
rollback attacks.
What's a rollback attack?
Rollback attack is a really
clever attack where you have
an old version of
let's say sign of
legitimate software that
has a known vulnerability,
and you trick the device
into basically
downgrading to a legitimate
but buggy version
of software so you
can exploit it.
You have to have support in
your hardware root of trust,
for example, and refuses to
build prevent rollback
attacks from occurring.
Those are the properties.
What's the product?
What did we announce?
Azure Sphere is
an end-to-end solution
that's composed of three pillars.
We have Azure
Sphere Certified MCUs.
I'm going to give
a deep dive on what
a Certified MCU means,
what properties does MCUs have.
An operating system, and
I said security services.
So, the Certified MCU
is provided by
silicon partners with built-in
Microsoft security technology,
provides connectivity
and guarantees
a dependable hardware to trust.
The Operating System is
secured by Microsoft,
guarantee we're going
to provide updates
for at least 10 years,
and it provides
a trustworthy platform
for IoT experiences.
The Security Service.
The Security Service
brokers trust between devices,
between devices in the cloud,
looks for emerging
threats through
failure reporting and allows
for renewable security.
I'll talk about that brokering
trust in a little bit.
So, let's get into what an
Azure Sphere certified MCU is.
Here's a term crossover
MCU in this slide.
All these Azure
Sphere MCUs are connected.
They have built-in networking.
They're secured with
this built-in security
technology which we call Pluton,
and it's a crossover.
What does that mean?
When you look at a typical MCU,
if you're in the space,
you're talking about
something like a Cortex-M.
Cortex-M has physical
address in it.
It lacks a lot of the properties
we're looking for.
The crossover MCU have
both the Cortex-M
and the Cortex-A.
Cortex-A gives us address
speed, address translation,
let's us run a high-low
operating system
based on a Linux kernel,
has SRAM Flash, and is protected
by a bunch of what we're
calling silicon
countermeasures that help
guard against software that
ends up being exploited.
So Pluton is the hardware root
of trust. What does it do?
It guarantees authenticity
of your software.
So it implements
Secure Boot through ECDSA.
It protects against
downgrade attacks.
It has the ability to view fuses,
protect against
an old but buggy version
of software ever being
run on the device,
protects the authenticity
of the device itself.
So it has its own
cryptographically-based identity,
which means you can always
tell when the device
connects whether it
is who it says it is.
Reduces supply chain risk.
What do I mean by this?
It's a great story
you guys can look up out
there of a certain model of
phone that one of the warehouses
was physically attacked,
and they rooted 52 models of
phone and put malware on it.
So when these phones
arrived at businesses,
they came out of the box
with the cameras on and
the microphones recording.
So having Secure Boot
guaranteeing that every piece
of software is signed
eliminating the ability
to have something
like a rooted or developed
mode that someone
can arbitrarily turn
on eliminates that type of risk.
The Pluton and Azure Sphere
MCUs are known about
from the time of their birth
at the silicon manufacturer.
So as that chip comes
out of the foundry,
we know about its identity.
We register that chip,
and then we can
basically know about the chip
throughout its lifetime,
which means we can tell what
an authentic chip
is and what isn't.
Now, it accelerates
common cryptographic tasks
like ECC and EFS.
Protects against
low-entropy attacks.
So Pluton is a true
random number generator.
It measures zone entropy.
So it looks, for example,
you cool the chip down to try to
reduce the space which is
generating random numbers,
it actually shuts itself off.
So that's all about Pluton.
There's the guarantees
that it provides.
A little bit more detail
for this audience.
It has a dedicated core
and it's owned
TCM memory that resists
side-channel attacks that
focus on a single core.
It's a true random
number generator,
and also implements remote boot,
measured booting and
remote attestation in silicon.
So it uses a digest
accumulator register
and a nonce register
which allow us to
implement remote attestation with
their services and look at
what software is actually
running on the device.
So why do we have Cortex-A?
I get this question
a lot from folks
who are in the MCU space.
Cortex-A is actually
bigger in area.
You should end up using
a little bit more memory
if you are running
an OS on there.
We think about security,
portability, extensibility here.
So security, basically,
because we get isolation.
Cortex-M chips don't have MMUs.
They don't have
address-space translation.
Having Cortex-A allows you
to have process-based isolation,
and I mean
the seven properties for
dynamic compartmentalization.
Also, there's a special
operating system.
I'll get into details
a little bit.
So the OS includes
our own runtime and
a custom Linux kernel that's
been focused on the IoT space.
So as an example,
we talked about
those default passwords.
The Azure Sphere operating
system doesn't have passwords,
and it doesn't have a shell.
It doesn't have user accounts.
Basically, took a portion
of this space that you
typically have in the OS
and just excised it,
which means we took
that attack surface out of
the equation. Of
course, authentication.
So we're doing mutual
author certificate-based
authentication.
We have our own
authorization mechanism
that's rooted in Pluton
to give permissions to
access to hardware
resources like peripherals.
So this is basic for those
who focus in the OS space,
desktop or server
operating systems,
but having an address-based
virtualization
means application code
just gets written once,
compiled through
platforms and runs.
This is not something you
typically have in an MCU.
With a physical addressing,
you're typically rewriting,
importing your application to
every single MCU platform
that you port.
So it's a much slower process
for innovation.
Source portability.
We have Linux kernel.
We're focusing on OSS.
Most libraries we often support
a large swath of
the POSIX Standards.
You can take common POSIX
libraries out there and
bring them to the platform.
We know the A7 compared to
something like an M4, AI,
where we'll have a headroom
for the future for bringing
new products to market
through this software update.
So what are these firewalls?
When I say that term firewall,
I don't mean a network firewall
where you have a white list,
and you're looking in
software, for example,
a table of IP addresses
you're looking for.
What I mean is that these
firewalls are like a mapping.
This mapping is
done in registers,
and when you can map a peripheral
to a core, so in this example,
we have multiple cores,
the firewall guarantees that if
another core tries to access
that peripheral over the bus,
that access is simply denied.
It's just a no op.
So being able to
program this firewalls,
and having enforced in silicon,
and having a "Deny
by Default" strategy
means that you are
guarding against
cross-cortex and cross-core
vulnerabilities.
This applies to every resource in
the system: Ram, network, flash,
and every single
peripheral flows through
this mapping in silicon.
So this means if you're
on one of the cores,
and a hacker attacks it and
they have access to yours,
and they want to hop
over and access a spy,
or access some of the SRAM
attached to the A7,
it's simply not possible.
Now, one of the interesting
property theories
that we talked about,
a lot of these silicon defenses
are sticky, and what
does that mean?
It means once you
program this mapping,
it cannot be reset
until the entire chip goes
through its reset process.
So even if the code that programs
the firewall is exploited or
has a privilege escalation,
an attacker cannot reset
the firewall and reprogram it for
access to resources it
didn't originally have.
Having that theme is
a write-once setting.
Finally, we have an MCU.
We have a traditional MCU
on this Cross MCUs is where
you do real time computation.
Real time access is
basically bare metal execution
with a traditional Artas.
Because of that
compartmentalization in silicon,
we prevent that software from
basically running amok other
than the Sandbox we provided.
So, basically, you can run
whatever you want there.
A lot of manufacturers have
their existing Artas
that they want to run,
and they're free to
deploy it and run it,
we just treat it
like an application.
So, we have a lot of
silicon partners that
have made announcements as
supporting these chips.
The first chips from MediaTek
is called the MT3620,
it's available on market now.
We're going to see a lot
more chips coming to
market in this space over
the next couple of years.
So, let's talk a little bit
about the operating system.
At the bottom, we're
running our own processor,
we're running in
trust zones and trust
zone parlance, and secure world.
We have a security monitor that
protects access to resources,
all those silicon countermeasures
I talked about are all
programmed from Secure World,
they can't be set
from normal world.
There were Custom Linux kernel,
these on-chip Cloud Services
for authentication
and connectivity,
and then you have
our application called the
Containers or Sandboxes.
Don't think about
a Docker Container.
In the space we're talking
about with a couple
of megs of RAM,
a typical application
is maybe 80 kilobytes.
So, we're talking about a Sandbox
that's reduced the surface
area for execution.
So, little more detail here.
So, as we mentioned earlier in
this curated user environment
there's no passwords,
no shell, no user accounts.
Basically, application has
its own manifest format,
the manifest is part of
the application package
that's signed by Microsoft,
we can parse that
manifest to determine
the exact resources the
application's requesting,
and guarantee that all those
resources are accessed.
Of course, we use
things like TLS,
to implement
mutual authentication,
those are run inside
the operating system
in normal world.
For Linux kernel has
its own Linux
security module that
protects resource acquisition and
manages access to Pluton services
like our random number generator,
and the security monitor in
addition to granting access
to hardware resources by
programming all those
silicon countermeasures,
also implements technologies
like erasure coding
to guarantee against
runtime corruption on Flash.
So, that's the OS, to jump
to the Security Service.
What are we getting out
of the Security Service?
How do we actually broker trust?
Well, we use the
Security Service to
connect all our devices and we
send our failure
reporting through it,
so we can do analytics and look
for attacks out in the wild.
We also use the
Security Service to push
updates back down to devices,
and Azure Sphere device updates
can't be turned off.
It's part of the
agreement that device
manufacturers except
that we're always
allowed to take an update
and push it out the device.
So, what are we getting
from attestation?
So, a run attestation allows you
to check not only the devices
running genuine software,
but it's running up
to date software.
So, where we're
leveraging attestation,
is that an updated device
is issued a very
short-lived cert.
So, think about it a cert
that only lives a day.
That cert then can be
presented to any service,
when it's AWS, or Azure.
If you can verify the cert chain,
effectively Microsoft is
vouching for the health of
the device for the moment
in time when attestation
was completed.
If a device is out of date,
it doesn't get the cert
it actually gets
something called a
quarantine cert,
that can only be
used to connect to
our update service and we can
force that update to occur.
So, this allows us to prevent-
basically allows us to take
the security services
and scale out beyond
Microsoft services by
using a certificate,
which is really a
common format that can
be understood in person.
So, of course, we use
Visual Studio, for development.
You might be surprised a lot
of times in the MCU space,
modern development tools
aren't very common.
So, bringing a Visual Studio
to market, I think,
there's a demo,
I think tomorrow, so you guys
can play with the device
and see how easy this is.
Taking up the development kit,
connects up to Azure and
send it to telemetry
takes about 10 minutes.
So, I'm running out of time.
So we're going to conclude.
The other thing I want
to talk about we might
not normally talk
about in this space,
is we talk a lot about
subscriptions right now,
subscription's a big way,
a lot of companies do business,
we didn't want to do that when it
came to securing your device.
We didn't want you to have
to think month to month,
is this device worth
securing or not?
So, when the chip is sold,
it comes with a license,
the license guarantees
the Security Service
is going to run
basically for 10 years,
we guarantee updates,
we'll manage
the service, the device.
So, that cost, I think,
is where the public price
we've announced is
less than $10 for 10 years,
including the chip.
So, we're hoping to basically
take some of the secure
service and push it
down market into the MCU space
with all the features we're
talking about in Pluton.
The thing is that's open.
So, we're licensing
the Pluton subsystem
for free to any
silicon manufacturer
that wants to implement
a sphere chip.
We are, of course,
it's Linux kernels GPL,
so that's open and available
for people to contribute to,
and it works with any Cloud.
So, because the way this
Security Service works,
if you're hosting all of
your service in WS, or Google,
or Azure, you can
leverage Security Service
for the security of
the device and work with
any service that's out there.
So, that is the 10,000
foot view Azure Sphere,
and I'm happy to
take any questions.
>> Thanks for the talk.
It seems like updates
are critical,
and there seems to be
a tension between what you
allow to be updated and
what may not be updated.
You mentioned the Firewall
can't be updated,
and yet other things
can be updated.
Obviously, if the firewall has
a vulnerability and that
you'd want to update it,
could you say a little bit
about what's the philosophy
and how you resolve the tension
to ensure that updates
can't be abused
and yet they will
occur when needed?
>> Yeah, great question.
Basically, anything
in software can be updated.
So, the real tension is what
do we push into silicon?
Is the functionality pushed into
silicon either simple enough
that we can have confidence
that it's correct?
So a bug in the Firewall
in silicon would
be not updatable.
That would be a core vulnerability
in the chip that we'd
effectively have to recall
all the chips and replace them,
or we try to use things
like pro verification.
So portions of Pluton
have been formally
verified to ensure that,
for example, the cryptographic
algorithms are correct.
If it's in software,
we're going to update it,
we're going to ship
updates out to it.
So, we try to draw that line
in terms of what we put
to silicon and what we keep in
software to determine
what's the deal.
But, it's tough because if
you ship a bug and putting
these cryptographic
algorithms in silicon
means they're
already more secure,
but it also means
if there's a bug,
you're going to have to actually
go out and replace the chip.
>> Great. Hello. Yes.
My name is Daniel.
It sounds like this may
incorporate the use of
a mini hardware security module.
And if so,
has it been submitted for
NIST validation and if so,
what steps are we're
shooting for for it?
>> Great. I don't
have all the details.
So, internally, we're
FIPS compliant,
and I think the team
working- because I
didn't mention this,
Pluton comes from a few decades
of experience with
Microsoft hardware.
So, this is internal silicon,
this isn't brand new.
It's internal silicon
has been defending
other products and
protecting other
products in your ecosystem,
that we've simplified a bit
and brought down
into the MCU space.
So, we've gone through
internally FIPS compliance.
We've not gone through
formal FIPS
certification but we get
asked about that
a lot and I think
that's going to be the next step.
Yeah. I guess that I
forgot this one thing,
I forgot to mention is that,
you mentioned in HSM, Pluton
just generates some key pairs
internally in silicon as well.
So, some of these chips
where you blow fuses
and take keys,
you do them in HSM, you
send them over wire,
we even feel like
that's insecure.
So, the keys are never
accessed by software,
even the most trusted piece
of software in
the device can never
see the private key.
It's all generated in
silicon and blown in fuses.
So, it was a good
question. Thank you.
>> Hi, Subin Mohan from UIUC.
Your motivation for this
originally you talked
about MCUs, right?
So, are there of
any real-time properties
that can be guaranteed or
real-time priorities in
the Linux OS that you
have designed for this or
can we add it in later?
>> I think you could look
at adding soft real-time,
but it's one of
the reasons why we have
that extra M4 Core.
That M core that was
on that diagram,
that's firewalled off is
that basically the M Core
Bare-Metal execution.
So, you can load
in RTOS, few RTOS,
some other RTOS on there,
and have full control
over the Core.
Microsoft doesn't
interfere with it.
So, if you needed to do
microsecond timing or something
like that you can do it there.
So because of all the
connectivity operations
and update the pieces that
go on in the Linux Kernel.
It's not really the
place you want to do
you real-time execution, yeah.
>> Does it have
control over the MMU
and memory management
as well for M Core?
>> The M Core is not
MMU, it has an MPU.
But it's given us some segments
in which to execute.
And then within
that space it's free to
do whatever it wants.
So, it's free to take
that piece of RAM that it's
given and treat it
however it likes.
Any questions?. All right,
great thanks if there
are other questions,
please reach out to me,
I'd love to talk
about it, thank you.
>> Hello, I'm Adam Chlipala and I
am going to be
talking about some of
our experiences applying
formal methods to systems
and some ideas for- now
that formal methods are
relatively practical
for this kind of
stuff what does that
mean about how we should
change the way that we
design our systems and take
advantage of some of
the structuring principles
that formal methods allow?
So, let me start out
by talking about maybe
the standard story people
have in their heads
about how we're going
to use formal methods where
we're building systems,
we somehow gather requirements
for what those systems should do,
we have designs, and
then we write some code,
and we iterate through applying
quality assurance methods like
testing and debugging
and code review,
and we do that enough, and we
become sufficiently confident
that we can release
something and let
people use it and not
be too worried about
serious security problems.
So, the standard story of
formal methods is that we
have it as an alternative kind
of quality control that we
apply without really changing
the parts of the implementation
approach that would
normally be used but we're
going to do some extra work to
prove that the system
really does what
it's supposed to do.
In particular, especially
for my own work,
what I'm talking about here is
mechanized end-to-end proofs
of functional correctness.
So, let me take a few slides to
briefly summarize what
I mean by those words,
and then I'll get into
some more applications
of the approach.
So when I say
mechanized proofs, I mean,
we use a theorem prover
software package
called Proof Assistant.
One my group uses is called Coq,
and what this means is you
can take the actual
source code of
your real system and write
a formal specification for it
as source code in
another language.
Finally, write a proof as
source code and yet in
another language that
establishes that
your system really meets
the specification.
We're going to feed all
of these three into
the proof checking
software package and it will
automatically validate
that the proof
actually establishes
the specification that
you have in mind.
When I talk about
functional correctness,
I mean, we're not just going to,
for instance, prove that
the system never crashes.
Were going to write down a rather
specific concept of correctness.
For instance, if all the inputs
up to this point
with a following,
then the output it
better be this.
Finally, when I talk about
end-to-end proofs, I mean,
we have halfway realistic systems
that are naturally
broken up into layers,
and the layers all have
their own specifications
and we can prove each layer
individually but
then we take the time to plug
all these results
together and get
an end-to-end guarantee that only
needs to talk about
sort of the top and
bottom APIs of a stack like this.
Many of the internal details
drop out of the trusted
computing base.
So, these kinds of ideas can
influence the ways that we
address classic trade-offs
in system design,
like the one between
performance and maintainability
where usually we
worried that as we improve
the performance of
a system that the
code gets harder
to understand but it's worth it
given the all the use that we
expect our systems to see.
So, one question that
we might have is,
is this pattern
fundamental where today,
we expect building a realistic
high-performance system
involves writing a lot of
intricate low-level code where
it's very easy to make mistakes
that jeopardize the correctness
or the security of a system?
So, let me try to
convince you that we can use
formal methods to actually
change this assumption
for building
realistic systems and
I'll do that with a,
just start out with
a concrete example that we've
already explored at MIT.
So, one area which was
mentioned as just part of
the story in the last talk
is cryptographic primitives,
and in particular,
elliptic curve
cryptography is one of
the most widely
used approaches for
instance for initiating
an HTTPS connection.
Here's some C code written
by one of the experts
on this kind of stuff
for the elliptic curve that
is generally viewed as
the easiest one to
implement efficiently.
I think this is code for
taking a big number
that's too big to fit in
one register of
hardware and squaring
it Modulo some
large prime number.
It is moderately intricate
and it's repetitive
enough that if you try to
audit this you might
easily lure yourself into
a false sense of security
and believe everything
looks okay.
This is just one part of
a larger piece of code
which historically this kind of
thing has all been
written by hand.
But it'll be nice to know
this code is correct and
there are few competing
approaches to doing that,
one of them is to find
a student or an intern
who's willing to read
through all these
lines of code and
write lots of invariance and
convince an SMT solver
that this is correct.
That's a wonderful
time-honored technique
and I won't try to
trash talk too much.
But what we could do
instead is wonder,
do we really need
to write code like
this to get
high-performance crypto?
Maybe it's an opportunity to
notice building formal proofs
of things is hard,
it pushes us towards simplifying
system implementations which is
an independently useful thing.
Maybe there's a better way
to write this where
we'll get a proof
and we won't have to
look at code like this.
So, just to motivate
a little bit more about
why this is
an interesting domain?
It is the standard devices
don't write your own
crypto code and
probably most developers
try to follow this advice,
most of the time,
we have a relatively
small number of libraries
that implement the most important
cryptographic routines.
But there's a
moderately large space
out there of
different cryptographic
algorithms that matter.
Then there are parameters
for those algorithms,
one important example is
a large prime number that
you use as the modulus
for arithmetic and
then there's
a small-to-medium set of
interestingly different
hardware architectures
that we want to run this code on.
When I was first learning
about this area,
I was really surprised
to hear that
for every element of
this three-way cross product,
the state of practice is to
rewrite all the code from
scratch sometimes an assembly
to get the best performance.
So, there really isn't,
there haven't been
very good abstraction in
the way that this kind of code
is developed and maintained.
That means there are lot of
opportunities for making
mistakes where we get
incorrect cryptographic
primitives that
can wreck your
security guarantees.
So we wanted to go at this
in the so-called
"Correct-by-Construction" way.
It'll be a way of
writing the code so at
every point all the
code you have is
guaranteed to be computing
the correct answer.
And there's a long history
of this kind of
formal reasoning and cryptography
where we typically start
with a property like,
I have a digital signature
scheme- no one
can forge signatures if they
don't know the right secrets.
And then we can apply
the idea of protocol
verification to show that
some mathematical
algorithm provides
that guarantee subject
the standard assumptions.
And then we could
do, for instance,
implementations synthesis
to come up with
low-level fast code that
provably implements
that algorithm.
I think the next talk in
this session we'll talk about
the other direction
implementation
verification where you have
the code already and
then you're going
to prove that it
implements the algorithm.
But let me talk about
the downward direction,
the way I've drawn this here.
Implementation synthesis
is what I'll be
focusing on in this project.
So to give an idea
of how we can in
a principled way derive
the code that we want to run
instead of just starting
with a pile of C
code or assembly.
We'll start out with mathematical
algorithms which
in this domain of
elliptic curves are all about
two-dimensional geometry.
And then typically
one substitutes
in a less obvious but more
efficient implementation
of points
which counter-intuitively
adds more coordinates
to make things faster because
we can run fewer
expensive instructions
when we rearrange
things this way.
And so this first step is
just a classic data structure
correctness proof in
the sense of abstract data types
and abstraction relations
and all that stuff.
So we write down an
abstraction relation
between these two versions and
prove that it's
respected by the code.
Then we have to implement
the individual coordinates
of these points which
are by themselves pretty
hard to get to run quickly
because every coordinate
is way too large to fit
in the registers that
a commodity hardware provides.
So we have to think about
division of numbers into
multiple digits and so we
prove big arithmetic in
this style to connect that part.
And then finally, an aspect
that I won't have time to talk
about in too much detail,
we have a verified compiler at
the end that takes
the functional programs
that are coming out
of this process that work
with infinite precision integers
and infers BitWits for
all temporary variables and does
other compiler
optimization things.
And then out pops
idiomatic C code with
particular types for
all the variables
that are being used.
The important thing is
each of those arrows
on the right side is carrying
a proof and they're all snapped
together in a common framework.
So we get that the
low level code is truly
implementing the
mathematical algorithm
that we started with.
And this whole pipeline
runs automatically.
It's not a new manual effort
to consider a new space.
I showed you three clouds.
When you change up one of
the second two clouds
this is automatic,
when you have a new algorithm
that's new work.
So our project is called
Fiat Cryptography.
It takes place within
the context of
a larger multi-university project
called Science of
Digg Specifications,
which paid for this lovely logo.
Which is reference
to the spy versus
spy comics for anyone who
is familiar with those.
And I've listed down
here my students
who've worked on this project.
This is basically a platform
for Correct-by-Construction
generation of
elliptic curve cryptography
implementations
and we hope later
other kinds of cryptography.
So what we basically
do is we're going
to think about the arithmetic
that goes into these algorithms
to a high level.
We're going to do
some functional programming
of the kind that you
might even assign at
a freshman programming class.
We're going to
represent big numbers
as lists of pairs of numbers.
Every pair has a compile-time
part and a run-time part.
The compile-time part is
the weight of that digit,
It's like how many bits
to shift it by.
The run-time part is
the actual digit value.
We're not going to be very
specific about which
weights are allowed,
whether we can have duplicate
weights or anything like that.
We just have lists and pairs
of numbers and we can write
down implementations of
classic operations
like multiplication.
That one works by just taking
all the cross products of
the elements of two lists.
And we can just write that as a
functional program that uses
famous higher-order functions
like Flatmap and Map.
And it's a very small
amount of code,
and we can write lemmas that we
prove in the coke theorem
prove that shows that
this multiplication
operation is related to
the normal
multiplication operator
in the appropriate way.
Then we can take ingredients
like that and put them
together into
higher level operations.
So this is one, that is
going to take in
two big numbers A and
B that follow a particular
digit representation
with n digits in this case.
This function is
actually generic in the
number n using polymorphism.
And then we convert each of
those fixed representations into
our flexible internal
representation.
We do the multiplication,
we run a mod operation which is
by convention called
Reduce here and
then we convert back out of
the flexible representation into
the fixed network format.
So this is a really nice from
a software engineering
standpoint..
This code is so much
easier to understand
than the C code that
I showed before.
But if we just say,
take this and treat
it like OCaml code or
Haskell code and compile
it and normal way
it's like one 100 or more
times slower than that
C code that I showed.
So we need to do
something about that.
And the approach we're
going to take is
a classic idea in compilers
called Partial Evaluation.
So we have for instance,
our multiply operation it's
parametrized on
the a static part.
Inflammation on
the digit representation
of numbers which could be
different for
different elliptic curves,
and then we have
the actual digit values.
So first, we'll specialize
this function to a particular
set of digit bit widths,
now all it takes in are
the digits themselves and
then we will reduce and simplify
algebraically that program until
all the overhead of a generisity
is gone and we have
a lean specialized
multiply routine
and then we'll actually
feed this into
the verified compiler
I talked about which will infer
bit widths and do it
the other thing is you
need to get C code from
the functional programming
view that we started with.
So how does this actually
pay off for performance?
So we, oh I should mention,
each of these arrows here is
a built-in operation of
our chosen theorem Prover Cox.
So this is all very
straightforward to do.
Specialization is just partially
applying a curried function
to some of its arguments and
the reduce stage is just
calling a built-in reducer that
is one of the standard
building blocks
of proof of program correctness.
So that's a very natural process.
So we get our C code
that looks a lot
like the code I showed
at the beginning,
at least at the abstract
syntax level.
It's not as nice to
read directly in
the concrete characters
that we output.
And if we can compare
performance on curve
25519 which is the for instance,
Google wants to talk
this curve to you if you
try to connect to
their main website.
If your browser supports
it'll use this one.
And here's some examples
of how many CPU cycles are
needed for one of
the top level elliptic
curve operations I
forget which one.
And we can see there's
our code up at the top there.
We generate both 64-bit
and 32-bit versions.
So these benchmark results
are run on a 64-bit machine,
so the 32-bit results aren't
super interesting
for performance.
And we're very close to
the best known assembly code
for this elliptic curve.
And in fact we are now as far
as I know generating
the fastest known C code for
essentially every
elliptic curve with
one automatic pipeline
that generates proofs.
And to demonstrate that
we scraped Information on
elliptic curves online and
tried to compute the set of
all the prime numbers that
anyone associates
with this field.
So we can automatically
generate implementations
for modular arithmetic
for all those primes.
And we did it for
both 64-bit desktop machine with
an X86 processor and
a 32-bit arm machine which is
actually an Android phone,
and we compare against
the previous highest performance
generic implementation
of this stuff
which is the new multi
precision library
which has multiple
variants one of
which actually is appropriate for
secure crypto-style
applications where you don't
leak information about inputs
to your arithmetic
through timing.
But we also compare it
against the version
that does leak information
through timing
which should only make it
harder for us to show
performance improvement.
And still over the space of
all these primes that we
spidered off the internet.
We were seeing typically
a performance improvement
in the range of 2X to
10X and we have formal proofs of
all these implementations which
the multi precision
library doesn't have.
And finally we
managed to convince
the team at Google that
manages the boring SSL library
which is a started out as
a heavily inspired by the
OpenSSL library but as
diverged a lot since then to
adopt our approach to replace
their grungy handwritten code
for elliptic curve arithmetic.
So the two most commonly used
elliptic curves are curve
25519 and P256 and
our code is in there now
for both of those with distinct
64-bit and 32-bit versions
and those student doing
an internship as we speak at
Google who will hopefully
have P384 the third most
frequently used elliptic curve
done in the next month or so.
And so this library
is used in Chrome,
it's used in Android,
it's used on Google servers and
so now about half of all
HTTPS connections from
browsers use are formally
generated implementations of
[inaudible] curve operations.
So, I started out
posing this question,
do we really need to
spend our time writing
intricate low-level code to get
performance in the systems
that we're building?
For talking about formal methods,
it's probably not a surprise
that we can, to some extent,
get rid of that bug
prone quality,
even if we keep writing the
same kinds of code as before.
But hopefully, I've
also showed how we can
remove the need to write
low-level code and do more
of our thinking in a nice
high-level way with more of
the nice software
engineering properties
that we prefer to have.
Here's a related question.
Whenever we add new
abstractions to a system,
we worry that there will
be some performance
cost for those abstractions,
even if it makes the system
nicer to think about.
If we do adopt these kinds of
end-to-end formal methods,
there could be ways to
lower the costs of adding
abstraction to
a system that we might
not think about if we have to
stick to traditional
implementations.
So, let me talk
about one way to think
about how we could apply
this idea in general.
I think the last talk
was a great example of
a classic approach to
security and isolation
in a system by imposing
various runtime mechanisms to
contain compartments
and limit what could
happen to different
parts of the system.
I think of a lot of different
examples from processors,
to operating systems,
to database systems,
as having their missions in
life are to provide a kind of
high-level imaginary view of
how a bunch of parts of a system
run and share resources.
Where we can imagine there are
these impenetrable walls between
the different sub-parts
of a world like this.
Every one of the parts
gets to be written in
a nice high-level language,
uses nice APIs,
we can pretend there are
dedicated processing,
resources, dedicated
storage, and so on,
for each one of these blocks.
Many traditional deployed
systems today literally
realized this picture and the way
hardware and software are set up.
But in general, what
we're trying to do
here is come up with
a real optimized system
that in some sense
can be having a dream and
imagining it lives in
that nice world but there's
a lot more resource sharing to
improve performance
in various ways.
We might call this top view
of things virtual machine,
maybe a kind of
older sense of the phrase,
which is just a nice
abstract view of
an executing system that
doesn't have to get into
the details of how we
do resource sharing.
Or we could just call it a
specification which is already
a common idea in formal methods,
and think about how we can use
compile-time reasoning to
show that a system truly
implements this
abstraction without
leaving any runtime residue
of the approach that
forces us to keep paying
a performance cost
each time we use the mechanisms
that we develop.
So, one direction
that I'm interested
in pushing on in
the near future is to try to
take this all the way
and move all of
our reasoning about
isolation to compile time,
and get good performance,
get good abstractions
without having
to make compromises there.
So, the idea is,
I wanted to think of a stack
of systems components as
essentially a platform for
efficient execution of
simple functional programs,
where we build up abstractions
that successively
show how to implement
the high-level
features that we're relying on.
I want the starting
specifications
we work with to be so simple
that we can more or
less just have a few
people read them and we'll
catch the major issues.
The code will be so
short that's feasible.
I want to try applying
a proof carrying code approach
where we just say,
if you want to run
your code on my system,
you need to give me a proof
of full functional correctness,
or I'm not going to accept it.
I think this is getting
to be feasible for
both software and
digital hardware,
and this should be doable
on an end-to-end way,
where we're gonna take
all the proofs that we
required to be provided
for all the components
installed on the system and
snap them all together
so that we get
a very small TCB that contains
just our proof checker,
as well as the semantics of
sort of the top and bottom
level APIs of the system.
Where the bottom is ideally,
a hardware description language,
and that the top is just the
nice high-level
functional version
of our applications and
the system API view
that they see.
If we do this right,
each of those top
and bottom levels
should be on the order
of 1,000 lines of
code and very doable to audit
and can touch major issues.
We should be able to,
by using this proof approach,
avoid all runtime
isolation mechanisms,
and push all of our reasoning
about that into proofs.
So, here's an example of
a stack of pieces that could
head in that direction.
So I want to start with
the top-level view
of the system is,
nice functional programs that
we can view as the specification,
and they would use
design patterns
like object capabilities,
so that just by
construction we achieve
proper least privilege and we
control the information flow
graph within parts of a system,
we achieve access
control just using
pointers in a type safe language.
Then we can rely
on a compiler that's going
to produce C-like code
from that point that does things
like static analysis to
infer object lifetimes,
to insert manual memory
management code so we
won't need anything like
a garbage collector.
Then our systems level of
programming language wouldn't
need to have a type system,
because if we're
already committing to
proving everything
functionally correct,
then a type system is
just an approximation
of functional correctness.
So we can leave
that out and expose
a view of memory as
an array of bytes directly,
but with structured
control-flow and functions
and other good stuff
like that on top of it.
The compiler for
that language will do things
like worst-case
running time analysis.
Tell us how long a function
might take to run.
This might depend
on some annotations
the programmer needs
to provide and
maybe prove some things about.
But then once you've done that,
we can output machine code
which is prepared to run on
machines in the
microcontroller class,
that was one of the parts of
the diagram the last talk showed,
where we don't have
virtual memory
or other address-space
protection.
We don't have interrupts.
We used to have a machine
that knows how to run
machine code functions
when you ask it to.
So then, what does
the processor do?
It keeps receiving IO events
from the world and for each one,
it knows which function to call
in the pilot machine code
that we've produced,
and that function
just runs to the end
and decides what to
do next including
signaling any response output
events that should happen.
It's safe to avoid using
interrupts or anything
like that here,
because we did
worst case execution
time analysis and
all of the code,
we don't depend on
virtual memory to isolate
the different parts of
the system because that was all
present in the original
functional code
through object capability system
and other such patterns
and preserved through
semantic guarantees
about all the levels bringing
us down to this point.
One thing that's kind
of hard about good,
worst case execution time
analysis of realistic code is,
predicting the cost of
memory operations given
complex cache systems.
So one other idea that
we're thinking about
is taking the high-level view
we have of code,
to preserve down through
this whole stack proved
accurate characterizations
of which objects in
memory each function
is going to need,
so that the the memory system
in the cache
coherence protocol can
move into place in the cache
whichever processor gets
picked to run a function,
guaranteed all the
object is going
to need so that when we
actually run the code,
we know exactly how long
it's going to take or
we can at least get a much more
accurate bound than before.
So that's the idea there.
To summarize, I think it's
worth exploring how some of
the challenges that we're
used to seeing as fundamental
in the design of
systems software,
can really be re-arranged by
committing to functional
correctness proofs
for all parts of the system.
This technology has
really advanced a lot.
I think in the next
10 years or so,
this will be the mainstream,
and I think it's
interesting to consider
what domains there
are out there where,
if we wanted to re-implement
all the complete software
stack from scratch,
this would be pretty feasible,
and I think there are
more cases of that than
we'd think from
the usual conversations
about this sort of stuff. Thanks.
Questions.
>> It's very impressive.
Could you say a bit about
how you would have
caught the problems
of interference between
speculative execution
and caching in this picture?
And more generally,
our processor abstractions have
the property that there are a lot
of details we don't
know about and in
a sense abstractions
are bad for security
because they hide from
the implementer properties that
the attacker takes advantage of.
So how does that fit into
this picture that's strongly
based on abstractions?
>> So let me start with
the second question or
maybe try to clarify
the intent of it.
If you're talking about
abstraction through
closed hardware designs from
manufacturers out there today,
then that doesn't fit so
well into our picture.
But if you think
about open-source
hardware designs like
are coming up in
the context of
the risk 5 instruction set,
then that fits completely
well into this picture.
And we're doing some work
in that area ourselves,
where you can assign
a semantics to
the hardware description
language that
includes timing of
all interactions
with the outside world,
and you can formulate what
it means for timing to be
independent of secret inputs
coming in on certain wires.
And then if you managed
to prove that theorem,
then you really have avoided
spectrum meltdown attacks.
But there is a challenge
there that I
think the architecture
community doesn't
quite know yet what
the actual changes
to the workings of
processors are,
to avoid those issues
while keeping performance.
So we'll just try
to be ready with
general proof tools for
whenever those
mechanisms are known.
>> So I've got a question.
>> Yeah.
>> So related to timing,
when people write
these functional
correctness specifications
how much do you expect
people to say about timing?
Like if they say I'm going
to send five messages
to somebody,
do they have to say exactly
when they're going to
send those messages so
they don't leak any bits
through the timing
of the messages?
>> Right.
One approach is to require
high level functional
specifications
that for each operation
you can run,
the functional program needs to
compute the running time
that it expects to have
in the real world.
That can be an opaque function,
you don't know what
it is but you know
it's well-defined
and deterministic.
It's hard to see how to avoid
heading in that direction,
to really avoid
all the information leaks
but this is pretty
speculative right now.
>> Thanks. One question is
about observing side channels
other than timing.
So for example, power side
channels or radio emissions.
What aspects of your work
do you think translate
well from timing analysis
to other analysis and
what aspects don't?
>> Yeah so those other
side channels I'm
really not very
well-informed about but if
someone who was
could come up with
some security condition that
applies to RTL designs then we
can probably incorporate
that in this framework.
I'm not informed enough to know
what that kind of
condition might look like.
>> So as you were
presenting the crypto-work,
the voice in the back of
my head was saying oh yes but
crypto-code has a nice clean
functional spec and it's
all self-contained.
It doesn't have to deal with
memory models and e-drops
and all these things.
And then we get to the end of
your talk and it seems like
your answer to that problem
is, we'll make it go away.
That's a great clean slate
design but do you have
any thoughts about how we get
from here to there incrementally?
Because that sounds like
a hard change to make.
>> We-
>> The crypto stuff
is easy to deploy
because it plugs into
the existing system and it,
observably makes it better.
But I don't see how you could
incrementally deploy
something like this.
Have you thought about that?
>> So I think I'm not suggesting
incremental deployment
in that sense but
just building some cool boxes of
the kind we heard about
in the last talk.
Using this framework which
then talked to
the rest of the world
through standard
protocols and interfaces.
>> Any other questions?
Just go ahead.
Thanks Chris.
So this is a talk
about project Everest
which is a joint effort
among several
Microsoft labs as well
as INRIA and Carnegie Mellon.
It's a project that
we've had going
for a couple of years
now that's aiming
to build and deploy
verified components in
the HTTPS ecosystem.
So I think you know
what HTTPS is,
even if you don't use it
pretty sure everyday.
Essentially when you connect on
the web to any secure website,
whether it's a bank
or your email,
you negotiated a secure channel
using a protocol,
a cryptographic protocol
that underlies HTTPS.
So on the surface the most
common usages through
this web protocol but
within HTTPS is is actually
quite a complex ecosystem.
At the heart of it is a protocol
called TLS, transport
layer security,
beneath which lie
several crypto-algorithms
and alongside it are
things like the Public
Key Infrastructure,
ultimately talking to
the network through a TCP.
Above it are clients and servers
that incorporate
this suite of protocols.
The trouble with HTTPS is that
although you should still use
it and it's significantly
better than not using
any protection at all,
the protocols in the space
and the algorithms
in this space had
been hit by attacks
and corresponding fixes
for 20 years or more.
And maybe the one that's got
the most attention is
this Heartbleed Bug
which in a way is
a very boring bug.
Heartbleed was essentially
exploiting a buffer overrun,
a memory-safety vulnerability to
compromise
implementations of TLS.
But there have been
other kinds of bugs too
that are independent
of implementations.
There have been design flaws in
the protocols and all the
mainstream implementations
have been subject to these flaws.
OpenSSL is the most widely
used implementation
but Microsoft's SChannel
is also very widely used.
There's NSS from Mozilla.
There other boring SSL things
that have forked from OpenSSL.
All of them have
been attacked and get
repeatedly patched.
So in 2016 we started a project
that had a five-year scope
so we're about
halfway through it,
and we had a few goals.
Our first goal was to build
a verified implementation
of the components in HTTPS.
Our goal is to actually
build these components in
a form where they are low level
and are efficient enough to be
deployed as is inside
the existing software ecosystem.
In doing so we are
building and improving
verification tools
that have been developed in MSR.
Fstar is a programming
language that
is a proof assistant in
the spirit of something like
cURL that Adam mentioned
but using an automated
theorem prover called,
Z3, that's also been
developed at Microsoft.
So, in pursuing project
ever us in building these
verified components we also aim
to produce more trustworthy
usable verification tools
and to grow expertise in
building this kind of verified
software at this kind of scale.
Finally, we strongly
believe that this kind of
security work has to
be done in the open
so everything that we
do is is open-source.
Including the tools,
Fstar is open-source
and all the verified
software that we build.
Were a large team of people who
who work on this at
several MSR lab so,
Redmond, Cambridge and India,
several of whom are in the room.
There's Chris and Tahena and
Jonathon at least that
I see who work on
Everest so feel free to
come find us and ask us
questions about this.
Aside from the MSR labs we
have collaborators at Inria in
Paris who we worked with there's
an MSR Inria joint
center at Paris
and we work with them
through this arrangement.
We have collaborators at CMU
and at the University
of Edinburgh,
and a long list of interns,
visitors and so on.
We're very open to collaboration
so if you're interested
in this kind of stuff
and would like to work
with us get in touch.
So here's where we are
at two and a half years,
we have verified implementations
of most of the the
key cipher suites
that are used in TLS.
For the moment, not look so
much at the public-key
infrastructure,
but have instead been looking
at a protocol called QUIC,
which is a new development
in this ecosystem.
So, QUIC is a new
networking protocol
that is undergoing a standardization
process at the IETF,
driven initially by Google,
and it's trying to
do TLS over UDP
in a new clean slate redesign.
So we have deployments
of our verified code,
in tests deployments
in three clients,
the Edge browser,
the cURL library that lets you
do command line code is
actually used in many,
many tools, but one
of it's usage is
just fetching pages from
a festering web content.
Ngnix is a Open Source Web Server
and we have a test
deployment in there,
but aside from
these test deployments,
we have two main production
scale deployments.
So, Windows is developing
an implementation of
QUIC called WinQUIC,
and WinQUIC uses TLS and
Everest is TLS runs in
WinQUIC and is now part
of the Windows
development builds.
We also, being Open Source,
our code runs also
outside Microsoft,
so Mozilla's NSS library
which is used in Firefox and
another Mozilla tools runs
Everest Crypto specifically
the Crypto-algorithms,
not yet the protocol stack.
So, when talking about
verification there's
always a question of like,
well, what do you
actually verify?
As a baseline for
all this kind of
work, we verify safety.
So without memory safety you
can't really get very far in
proving anything further.
That's the baseline level of
abstraction that
you need to prove,
so we prove safety
for all our code.
Then depending on the component
that we're verifying,
we pick properties that
we think are the most suitable
for those components.
So usually, this means
at least functional correctness,
but for certain components,
we will also prove things
like cryptographic security,
meaning that we bound
the probability that
an attacker can
break a certain
crypto-construction.
Despite all our proofs,
you may ask, will Everest
be perfectly secure?
The answer to this is no.
All this verification
work is based
on a set of assumptions,
both with respect to the
specifications that you write.
So, if you're skeptical
about Everest or any
verification process
for that matter,
you need to study
the specifications
that were actually
proven by the code and
convince yourself that
the specs actually
mean what you think they mean.
Specs are written with
respect to a model,
and our models try to be detailed
and cover all classes
of known attacks,
but there may be
new classes of attacks
that we're not aware of
that may become more
or less inadequate.
Also a verification
tool chain places
trust in a number of
components including F-star,
the Z3 term proven that we
use on C compilers and so on.
Those are part of
the trusted computing base.
Despite these limitations,
the general methodology of using
computer-aided verification
has some clear advantages;
verification is automated.
It may take several hours,
but you make a change,
and you want to
know if your change
was breaking a system invariant.
Well, the verification system
is going to tell
you as part of a continuous
integration system.
It's the way in which you can get
approved to work at this scale is
by breaking it up
into components,
and so verification is
modular and compositional,
meaning that you can
take as a component say,
a particular crypto
construction that we use
inside TLS and also use it in
some other component
which is for instance,
our usage of TLS and QUIC
is a great example of this.
TLS was intended for
use initially over TCP,
but the same crypto protocol
can also be used in
a different setting like QUIC.
So, the programming and
verification tools that we
use at the source level
is a programming
language called F-star.
F-star makes use of Z3 to
prove verification
conditions that
arise as you try to
write your program.
So, after you write your
F-star program and verify it,
you can compile it
either to OCaml
or in a tool that we've
developed as part of Everest.
You can extract
your F-star code to C,
and then compile it using
a C compiler and link it
with the rest of the system.
So, let me do
a small demo of this.
Is that big enough in the back?
Yes? Okay. So, this is
F-star running in max,
and an F-star program,
it's syntax superficially
looks a bit
like functional languages
like OCaml or F-sharp,
but within this framework
you can encode other DSLs.
So, I'm showing you
here a DSL that we have
an F-star for writing
C like programs.
This demo is a very simple
example that's showing
how you may copy the contents
of one array to another.
Copy from the Source
Array to the dest array.
The way in which you do
this copy is really simple,
it's a recursive function
that assigns the current byte
of source to dest and then
recurses on increasing
the counter by one.
Now, when you try to write
such a program you're forced
in F-star to prove various
basic properties about it.
So, you see these
comments that I have
here that say that at
various points in this code,
F-star will force you to prove
temporal safety for instance.
Meaning that you cannot access
a memory location unless
you prove that the memory
location is currently live.
Or when you do
an integer operation,
you need to prove that
there's no integer overflow.
So having written this code,
you can ask F-star to check it,
and it'll say, in
this case says yes.
But if I forget
a precondition, for instance,
I try to use the source array,
without knowing that
the source array is live,
and I asked if so to verify it,
it'll complain
pointing at a location
here that says, "Well,
at that index this says live",
you couldn't prove
that the buffer
that you were accessing
was live at that point.
So, this first attempt
here is just proving
that copy is safe to run.
It doesn't prove anything about
what copy actually accomplishes.
So, this bit of the spec
here is an insurer's
clause which says,
at the end of running this code,
there's something that
you can assume is
true about the state
of the program,
and in this case
the ensures process is true.
So, you don't get
anything if you don't
get any functional
correctness property
out of this version of copy.
But here's another
version of copy
where it's the same code
as I showed you before,
but it's now augmented with
the spec that tells
you that after you run
copy in the final memory H1
that results after
running this program,
the source and the destination
buffers are equal,
which is what you might
expect from doing copy.
So, F-star like such agrees
with the specification.
So having verified your program,
you can compile your program
to see and here,
I did this just a
little while ago,
so this is an extraction of
the previous program to see,
and notice that when
you extract a C
you just get C-code
that you would
expect with
all the specifications
erased and with no remaining
runtime checks or anything.
All the verification is static.
So, the stellar
verification generally
imposes no additional runtime
performance overhead.
Alright. So, that's
a sub language
that I showed you in F-star for
programming at the C-level
of abstraction,
but to get performance code
especially in some of
these crypto applications,
you need to go beyond C, and so,
we have another DSL called
Vale which is a DSL
embedded in F-star
for programming at
the assembly level of
building verified
assembly programs.
So, with these tools
we aim to build
TLS protocols like it,
and for TLS the domain security
goal that you're after
is to show that TLS
establishes a secure channel.
Meaning that you get
a channel between
the end points that is authentic,
meaning that an adversary
cannot inject
false data into the stream,
and is confidential.
Meaning that an anniversary
cannot distinguish
between the communication of
random bytes and
a secret on the stream.
The TLS protocol has
through the years
been designed has been
vulnerable in many ways,
but TLS 1.3 is the latest
version of the protocol
that is now a ITF
proposed standard.
In the process of us
verifying TLS 1.3,
we discovered many
potential protocol flaws
in earlier versions of
the design and proposed.
I think we have
six proposals that have been
incorporated in the proposed
standard that arose as
a result of us doing
our verification work.
The ITF has generally been quite
receptive to this at least in
the TLS Committee has
been receptive to
this kind of formal work as well.
The standard for instance
cites both hours, as well as,
several other formal models
of TLS as a validation of
the design of the protocol.
So, the way in which we model
cryptographic security and prove
it is in the following manner.
So, you have a concrete
implementation of TLS
that's using a crypto provider,
a crypto library that's
implementing
the actual algorithms,
and you have
an application program
which may also represent
the adversary
interacting with TLS.
What we do is a general proof
methodology is to show that
this concrete version of TLS is
indistinguishable from
an ideal version of TLS,
about which we can prove that it
actually implemented
secure channel.
The way we do that is by
verifying the crypto library,
and then making use of a
cryptographic hypothesis to show
that these two clients
of this library are
indistinguishable except
for a security parameter,
probability determined
by a security parameter.
Having done that, we can
then approve the
ideal version of TLS.
Information theoretically
secure with
no more cryptography
in the picture.
With that step of
the proof complete,
you can then show
that an attacker
cannot distinguish between
concrete TLS and ideal TLS
except also for
some probability epsilon.
So, that's our general
proof methodology
at the top level.
In order to apply
this methodology,
there are various
proof steps that
become necessary along the way.
So, here's the structure
of one simple workflow
through TLS.
So, TLS is a socket-like API.
You connect.
You try to create
a secure socket.
That triggers the run of
a TLS handshake that's
going to negotiate keys
between the two endpoints,
which then requires actually
sending some plain text
bytes out on the wire
which will then the TLS
record layer sub protocol
is going to add some padding
to hide lengths.
Then finally at the very bottom,
there's going to be the addition
of a ciphertext and a
Mac to protect the actual
message that goes out.
So, at each level,
we have various
proof obligations.
So, at the very bottom,
you need to prove that the
crypto that you actually
implement is
functionally correct.
We actually also prove
that it's resistant to
a class of timing side channels.
So, as Adam alluded to,
we have a library called HACL*.
That's a library implemented
in the sea-like subset of F*,
where we have proofs of
many crypto algorithms
whose performance
compares quite favorably with the
best hand-written C. So,
it's actually
interesting I hadn't
seen Adam's most recent slide.
It looks like their
version of curve is
slightly faster than ours,
but this 64-bit version of
curve is significantly faster.
Then it's like 2x faster than
a hand-written version of
the same curve in OpenSSL,
which was a 32-bit version
of the curve that
was the only one
that OpenSSL had until recently
at the level of C. So,
using our verification
technology,
we are able to write
64-bit versions of the code
and be confident that
we got it right.
It's actually this code,
this code from this library,
these are crypto library in C,
is the code that we have
deployed in Firefox.
So, we have the curve 25519,
but also some other algorithms,
ChaCha20 and Poly1305 are
deployed from HACL* in Firefox.
That said, the code
generated from HACL is
competitive with C,
but the best implementations
in assembly are still
significantly faster.
So, using Vale, we have verified
the assembly code in
OpenSSL more or less as is,
and as you'd expect if we get
performance that is competitive
or identical to the OpenSSL code
that we started from.
At the level of data streams,
we prove that
a distributed invariant
that the reader
enter the protocol,
reads from a prefix of
the stream that the writer
has sent so far.
In order to send
messages down the wire,
we need to prove that parsing
and formatting code are correct.
At the high level
domain invariant
that we're after is that if
the application sends a message
m and it gets formatted,
then encrypted and
decrypted and then parsed,
the receiver receives
exactly the same message
that was sent.
The way we do this is rather than
writing parsers and
formatters by hand,
which can be very
tedious and error prone,
we start from
a high-level description
of the message formats from
RFC text and synthesize
via metaprogramming,
a low-level implementation in C
of parsers and formatters
for those message formats.
So, I'm running out of
time. I should wrap up.
So, I'll finish with
some high-level perspective.
So, we're building
verified components
motivated primarily by HTTPS,
but in doing this,
our components that we
produce are reusable in
other contexts as well.
So, Quic is one such example
that I mentioned briefly earlier,
but some of the work that we're
currently doing
also involves using
our crypto libraries to
build things like verified
authenticated data
structures that are used
in things like blockchains.
Recently, there's
some interest in
using our crypto
libraries to verify
the correctness and security
of post-quantum
crypto algorithms.
Our verified parser and
formatted generators,
although we're using them in TLS.
We also see that they have
applications in other secure
messaging scenarios for
instance inside a kernel
or in communications between
VM and kernel and so on.
Another high-level
perspective about
Everest is that
rather than trying
to build a completely secure
stack from the ground up,
what we're after is building
verified islands of trust
inside the existing
software ecosystem,
and we think there's
value in doing
that in a way verification is
a lot about the blame game.
If we deploy our code
inside an existing
operating system
Linux or Windows or whatever,
the entire system is
still vulnerable to bugs,
but any such bug is going
to be outside of our code.
If a patch has to be shipped,
it's not us that's going to be
shipping a patch,
someone else will.
Now, finding these islands of
trust in which
verification can add
value requires
some careful thinking
and we think that standards-based
cryptography and networking is
a really good match for it,
partly because there's
a very widely accepted
common wisdom
that you're supposed to leave
crypto to experts and
not try it all your own.
So, there's an opportunity for
a well-designed
crypto library and
protocol library to be used as
a drop-in replacement for
the existing code
that's out there.
Also, I think another
thing that we're
quite encouraged by
is that the standards process at
the IETF and elsewhere is
increasingly receptive
to this kind of
formal spec and and validation,
partly because prior versions
of these protocols
have really been badly
beaten up by a cycle of
a taxon and patches.
So, we think there's
an opportunity there.
So, that's it.
I'll leave you with that image.
It's our goal of
trying to build and
deploy verified
components in HTTPS.
>> Hi, Rebecca Wright,
Rutgers University.
Thanks for the talk.
So, you noted at some point
that of course all of
these proofs are dependent
on the model and
that there is always the
potential for attacks
outside of the model.
In the practical usage here,
do you have sort of a sense
whether it's sort of inherently
a cat and mouse game that
will continue
indefinitely or whether
they're in a practical
sense some kind of
convergence to capturing most of
the meaningful potential attacks?
>> I think at a certain level,
there's a high level spec
about what the protocol
is trying to achieve.
I think we're reaching
a convergence,
but there's always
the possibility of
vulnerabilities at
the lowest level
that our models
don't account for.
So, for instance, we have
proofs of resistance
against a certain class
of side channel attacks,
where we didn't anticipate
spectre and meltdown either.
So, although we think our
code for the particular kind
of code that you write,
it's not vulnerable to
these kinds of spectre
and meltdown attacks,
our proofs certainly
don't account for this.
So, those kinds of
scenarios may still
occur in the future.
>> Another questions.
Okay. Well, let's thank
the speaker again
and head for lunch.